[Music]
hey [ __ ] kickers why don't you get a
nice cool glass adams ale and cozy on up
next to the fire
come along for a ride
for this next episode of congratulations
[Music]
oh yeah we're here dude i have a [ __ ]
cap you know what man i've been playing
this red dead redemption
on uh
twitch
and uh really been getting into it so uh
my fiancee got me a bolo tie and a
[ __ ] cowboy hat
so i'm getting good use out of them dude
and i look really actually sexy to be
honest if you really look through
uh true if you really look in your true
heart you're not you know and you wanted
to get a wiggle on of that answer you
would understand
that i look sexy as [ __ ] dude imagine me
with a [ __ ] long black
shirt on
like a long sleeve black shirt on just
this hat and like some badass sunglasses
just on a [ __ ] horse
slowly ride not fast you know what i
mean
just like this
just slow riding like this right
where it kind of looks like i'm
maybe possibly sitting on a sibian but
also i'm on a horse though
right if you just because you could see
the whole thing right now it looks good
monisibian right now it looks like i'm
on a sybian because i'm behind it that
you can't see the bottom right
but
in actuality
i'm on if you saw the whole thing you
saw him how i'm on a horse i would look
[ __ ] really badass and i won't take
any [ __ ] other answer honestly i
would look [ __ ] amazing with a long
black shirt and a [ __ ] so why don't
you cozy on up to that like button
why don't you cozy on on up to that
light bulb
why don't you [ __ ] nail that
subscribe button to the counter right if
you're a fan of this
[ __ ] podcast why don't you nail that
subscribe button up against the counter
so i played red dead redemption 2 and uh
i have a good time dude i like red dead
redemption 2. finally a video game i
like yes dude why because you can do it
all you can chill you can go [ __ ]
feed your horse you can run around shoot
people you can kind of you know what i
mean rob a bank you can you can ride the
horse real fast and then [ __ ] jump on
a train to get away from bad guys it's
[ __ ] killer [ __ ] dude
so thank god that there's red dead
redemption 2 because i'm out here
playing outlast 2 and [ __ ]
you know
uh
uh [ __ ] donkey kong it's not it's not
fun anymore here's the thing i am
guilty of i am a person who is too old
to play these [ __ ] games where
you're going to be born like fallout 3
or
the old games of the past because
they're not fun anymore mario excuse me
but jumping on the [ __ ] koopas and
into the green [ __ ] uh
the pipes
it's not fun anymore i'm 41 i'm a tall
drink of water you know i'm not two feet
anymore so i can't be playing them shits
dude so bring on some real life [ __ ] but
also make it nice dude and that's what
red dead redemption does i don't want to
talk about video games for too much but
if you want to follow us on twitch it's
flex avenue dude we're right on the
corner of flex avenue and uh twitch i
guess but that's where it is yeah dude
but i'm southern now man and i just but
i you know
it is what it is i i i you know i have a
i have a good time on there too it also
makes me forget about
uh thing you know i get now i told you i
get like
you know through all this therapy i get
escapism you know because when i'm in
therapy i'm doing the [ __ ] i'm doing it
hard and i'm [ __ ] confronting [ __ ]
and i don't like to confront [ __ ] like
you know
not that anything crazy bad happen to me
but like my childhood like i don't like
talking about that like the
uncomfortable [ __ ] that happened like i
don't like talking about it but now i
got video games i could talk about it
and then i go and i get on my horse for
a [ __ ] hour and a half and you know
what i mean
just get on my [ __ ] horse for an hour
and a half
and have a good time dude um
but yeah man because it's like the
[ __ ] hustle and bustle of the world
right like the [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] that
just i can't even take anymore and i'm
and i'm uh
you know i don't know if my fiance would
say i'm a chilled dude but like
you see me laying
down
you know you seen me on a chair
right i look like hot lava just [ __ ]
destroying it i mean i chill i chill
hard
sometimes i don't even i just look like
a pile of clothes like i'm just hanging
you know
right
but
you know
stuff gets to me
like the [ __ ] emmys was on and i
don't want to see it
i don't want to watch it
because i don't like actors just you
know basically
good job me i did i did do that well
didn't i
you know actors just talking about
you know also in times like these
it's just like oh did you [ __ ] didn't
you just play a mailman
yeah but i just want to say thanks and i
also they're bringing up [ __ ] that isn't
even a problem anymore the the olympics
in [ __ ] when the when
that
you know movies like munich they really
speak to it's like dude it's not even a
[ __ ] problem anymore and you got
[ __ ] uh some chick on
the show uh
what's the [ __ ] show god damn it god
damn it never remember [ __ ] dude
what's the [ __ ] show with the
lev
there was a show on [ __ ] tbs and it
would have been the best one to use with
this [ __ ] joke i'm finding it dude
come along with me come along with me
come along with me i'm finding it tbs
show it's called like levit levitt lev
levitt levitation or some
leverage leverage was leverage a show
let's look was it leverage tbs show
leverage leveraged tv series yep that's
what it was
[Laughter]
leveraged dude
worst title of all time man
leverage was what it was it had a guy
who had [ __ ] long hair that shouldn't
have long hair in it
right and it was called leverage
dude some guy who's some [ __ ] you
know what i mean like the third lead of
leverage and and darfur
and people who just you know and it's i
gotta listen to some guy
and what you what do you do you show up
you eat some [ __ ]
kale guacamole and peanuts you say a
[ __ ] few lines nine times in a row
you shoot it from four different angles
and then you [ __ ] go home
huh
so please
tell me about darfur
tell me about anything systemic please
[ __ ] everything is so [ __ ]
systemic nowadays people just be like
well you know it's systemic and you're
like i'm just in line at the grocery
store trying to buy lettuce
well it's just it's a systemic problem
okay
boop
450.
thanks ma'am it's [ __ ] everything is
systemic everything's his budwer bug bud
what the [ __ ]
there
what am i
there are these
what's the word there are these
buzzwords [ __ ] dude
there are these buzzwords that people
you problematic systemic you know what i
mean they just come in
well you know why
[ __ ] platt is in right now it's a
stomach
it's systemic plaid is it really it's or
is it fall
is it problematic
or is it almost the winter
i just don't it's like dude it's so i'm
watching that i didn't watch the emmys
but then sure enough i don't want to
hear about the emmys i'm not on twitter
i'm not on [ __ ] social media really
except for instagram twitch and tick
tock and [ __ ]
you know what i mean i'm only on [ __ ]
instagram tick tock twitch
you know i check safari and i look at
the news apple news but i'm not really
on social media dude
you know
[ __ ] patreon and um
and it's like dude they're just like
here's the thing that's just
not so
all right
that means takes place
where in la okay
twitter i don't know what is worse
you're watching the emmys and you're
like hey what's what's going on here
because i saw a few clips since then
what what where's uh oh oh more people
are here than i thought there would be
because we're in a right pandemic this
is a global pandemic and la
they've been taking this [ __ ] real
seriously
but why does
why does rita wilson
why
why is she so close to cedric the
entertainer
she she's not six feet apart
oh well it's because they have masks
they don't have masks on
unless they're not really rita wilson
and cedric the entertainer
unless they're
in rita wilson
and cedric the entertainer masks
but they're not holed up
it's really rita wilson and cedric
entertainer with no mascot oh so the
emmys must be
in dallas this year
oh but they're not
well
why did all these stars fly to dallas oh
they didn't they didn't because it's in
la so why aren't they wearing a mess
because the masks were the emmys were
exempt from wearing masks so basically
it's off then
it's all
and i am not an anti-mask person i am
not an anti-vaxxer i was waxed the [ __ ]
up
felt chills
got shot twice after the second one felt
chills nine hours later that's how i
know it's real
i wear my mask indoors always unless i
got a running quick to get a straw at
the coffee bean right but sometimes i
put my my shirt over it because i won't
be able to feel comfortable i'll go by
the rules you know your boy he goes by
the [ __ ] rules
and you know why if you listen to this
podcast why do i go by the rules so then
if something gets [ __ ] up that's on
you
i played the game
so if you're saying well these guys
from ted lasso don't have to wear a mask
these guys
from that [ __ ]
show with brian cox that crystally
always forgets the name of because it's
regular succession that's they don't
have to wear it well if they don't have
to wear it
then it's not that serious
spread the [ __ ] out
so then i'm i'm like oh well [ __ ] all
this [ __ ] because it's la right gavin
newsom is like well yeah i gotta go wear
the mask don't wear the master where the
master on the middle everyone wear the
mask except the emmys you gotta wear the
masks
and then you're looking at the [ __ ]
movie or the music awards whatever it
was the other week when conor mcgregor
and machine gun kelly they're not
wearing a mask but everyone's handling
them they're all wearing [ __ ] masks
so it's like
then they're on twitter and they're just
screaming hey you [ __ ] how
could they [ __ ] do this you know this
is so irresponsible
is it
is it irresponsible
the problem is
you made the sauce the media we bought
the sauce
we were like media all right we bought
the sauce and now
you you're televising the group
that sold the sauce
and they're not eating the sauce
and now i still gotta [ __ ] rub the
sauce all over my [ __ ] steak
when i eat it [ __ ] off
so i will put the mask on when i go into
an establishment if that's the rule but
guess what dude i take a right off when
i get out i'm not wearing it outside
dude
it's so annoying i was driving by the
other day i saw a guy wearing a [ __ ]
mask sitting alone
nobody was within a hundred feet of this
dude he had a mask on what's he [ __ ]
think coronavirus is j like what's he
think it is a ninja
oh i didn't see you there
what do you think he's my [ __ ] friend
mclovio perez in high school
every time i was in [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you're right there
that was his move dude i'd be eating
lunch i'd be like oh [ __ ] i didn't know
you're there
is that what the [ __ ] coronavirus is
was my because coronavirus my friend
maclovio perez from high school
um it's indoors
nobody's wearing a mask
nobody gives a [ __ ] it's it's like
they're laughing in you
here's the other thing too
like i said i'm not an anti-mask
anti-vaxx dude i got the vaccination
is it real or not does it [ __ ] help i
think so but i don't if you don't want
to get the mask or the vaccine don't get
the vaccine i don't really give a [ __ ]
okay
um i just did it because i thought it
was for the greater good but here's the
deal
you got to understand that if you say
don't wear the mask to the people on
this show it's going to [ __ ] enrage
people and whether or not those people
who are anti-vaxx or are anti-masks
whether or not you know history will
tell were they idiots because a lot of
people are like [ __ ] anti-mass
anti-uh vax people they're [ __ ]
morons a lot of people say that only
time will tell okay only time will tell
but you have to know if you're telling
if you're perpetuating this from the
media and then you televise this [ __ ]
people not wearing the mess and they're
making the sauce
you have to understand they're gonna
feel more right
and they're gonna get angrier
and it's only going to be bad so all i'm
saying is
[ __ ] the emmys
you know
or [ __ ] these emmys
it's just like dude it's just it's just
like
i get it i get why [ __ ] people are in
queueing on like [ __ ] they're
laughing at us you know what i mean it's
like i don't believe that [ __ ] but i get
why they do
nobody means what they [ __ ] say not
anymore
nobody means what they [ __ ] say and
that's all i'm trying to [ __ ] do is
mean what a goddamn say
it's so hard to understand you know it's
so hard to mean what you say anyway
right
because because it's so hard to be
honest with yourself isn't it isn't it
isn't it
you know when you're a kid and they're
just like yeah you're you're [ __ ]
beautiful you're beautiful it doesn't
matter yeah so what he said you're fat
that you're you're the kid in class said
that you look like a [ __ ] you know
you look ugly or they don't like your
hair you're beautiful everybody's
beautiful
and then you grow up and you're like
yeah
i am kind of beautiful but also i
secretly know i'm not really beautiful
right what do you mean beautiful on the
inside
the whole [ __ ] mr hustle trophy [ __ ]
i got mr hustle one year when i was
[ __ ] like 13 nah i was younger than
that i was probably 11 in tennis i got
mr hustle
and it's just like i knew it was
[ __ ] they were like you really were
you really did hustle ah [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude even as a 11 year old i
was like dad give it to me because i
wasn't the most improved or the best or
the highest score they gave me mr
[ __ ] hustle
i don't know man
um
i just couldn't believe that any [ __ ] i
mean i could believe it but i couldn't
believe it let's get it to something a
little [ __ ] lighter we're gonna do a
new segment okay this is a new segment
that i have on my podcast
all right i know everyone wants me to do
um uh craigslist [ __ ] again and i will
in the future but right now this is a
new segment and this
segment is
video of the week all right
so welcome to the new segment video of
the week uh and here it is this is
posted by mr give your girl back
and i'm going to play it
and for the people listening i'm going
to describe it but you know for the
people watching you'll see it uh this is
a
car accident
on the scene of the car accident and i'm
going nowhere that why he got smacked
cooked he tried to bend the car [ __ ]
one going nowhere [ __ ] gonna spit it
right there in the middle of the street
shout out okay two cars dropped oh oh
[ __ ] another car almost crashed oh [ __ ]
soda cup ain't cool we got the goddamn
car we got the goddamn minutes of
minutes to call here
what the [ __ ] going on caught it only in
cleveland shout out
cuz that been running oh [ __ ] any
sliding that [ __ ] out of the car
that been running off for three aaa
batteries
that being running awful uh uh
vegetable oil
power steering fluid dude the [ __ ]
car is this big and there's a guy in it
like this just whipping around it sounds
like one of the cars from the
jetsons and it's so little two cars are
crashed on the scene of the crime
and then another [ __ ] car a pickup
truck almost crashes
into the frame
this [ __ ] little bitch-ass car comes
in and he's like only a cleveland curt i
live when people are like only in
wherever my city is like crazy [ __ ]
doesn't happen in every [ __ ] city
only in [ __ ]
idaho falls
only in albany
this [ __ ] little
car dude this was video of the of the
week when i saw that little bitch-ass
car [ __ ] driver and then the guy
comes in screeches somehow it's like
going that fast he says what happened
you're what happened
you're the icing on the cake
love it
listen to the way this guy sounds like i
don't know where that why you got smack
cook cool he tried to be in the car
[ __ ] one going nowhere [ __ ] spinning
right there the middle street
show oh oh [ __ ] cool all right there oh
[ __ ] show the cup hey cool we got the
goddamn
car we got the goddamn minutes of
minutes to call here so
what the [ __ ] going on carter only in
cleveland's show
different syllables that been running
off for three triple h
oh sho
just [ __ ]
love it dude
let me
get this guy
um
that i follow on instagram
oh my god dude this makes me this guy
makes me laugh so
[ __ ]
much
let me find it i might have to cut
because i gotta find it um
[ __ ] instagram what is it instagram
what
backslash
yeah
slv
sounds
is that it
there it is wait no that's not it
i gotta search instagram slv
sounds here it is oh underscore slv
underscore
sounds with two s's dude
this guy
okay i did the video last week or two
weeks ago about the chunkling croissants
that was
that made me laugh harder than maybe any
video i've ever [ __ ] heard okay and
we did the whole breakdown it's on
youtube you could watch it it's on
[ __ ] episode 2000 or 209 why do i do
that why do i say 2009 dude 209 but this
guy dude
all this guy does
is find first of all there are so many
videos of this guy finding people with
fake jordans all right or like
ridiculous ugly shoes and then he makes
a song about it
and [ __ ] like zooms in on their shoes
and it's so [ __ ] funny dude now here
i am i'm gonna play it i'm gonna play it
let me go let me go down actually let me
go to see all hold on oh no that's or
they're gonna let me see all of them
i'm gonna have to play it from my phone
huh
show more posts from see but here we go
um
here we go this is what he does let me
let me actually play the first one i
ever got because this [ __ ]
sent me dude
all right dude we're back look we had to
find it i couldn't find it it actually
took a long time to [ __ ] do it
because they wanted me to sign into
instagram so i got it on tick tock right
here i hope i even get rid of got rid of
all the [ __ ] filler here we go dude
i believe in him i believe he did that
dude you didn't have to wait around for
too long because i would get rid of came
through even though i even get rid of
also ivan stays in the game here we go
[Laughter]
the guy's running by on his bicycle and
he goes and the guy's screaming out what
the hell
okay and the guy on the bike is does you
can obviously see it's only his leg
which i love it dude and the guy tries
to [ __ ] roll away a little bit but
he's he keeps going hold on man hold on
hold on man hold up please please please
please who is that coming out the
goddamn pick and running
oh brother who is that on the logo
because jordan never did that move
just chicken dude the guy's got fake
jordans on jordan never did that move
oh my god dude
they never what eve got that shoe
brother got the baby blue got them got
them
[Laughter]
the james with the air max bottom man
brother come on let me three things
three things
oh man let me
oh
i got the coconut
got the sky blue man take them all thank
you man
what a dick
dude
yeah dude he always just got three
things for you brother i got a
and then he goes
pluck and then he says
he hits him and he says
take him off so dick dude also only
black guys would flick and say pluck
pluck pluck dude that's such a [ __ ]
oh man i i kid my the [ __ ] black kids
in my school used to do that they used
to call flicking plucking
i love it dude loving it
hold on
wait
[Laughter]
[Music]
take a mom
staying around dude
it's so good man
take them off wait and then this one
[ __ ] sent me
dude this guy's walking around in a
wrestling
in a wrestling outfit
eddie [ __ ] man brother oh you're
really a wrestler man
oh
god damn
dude i love that already breaking in a
song like the the reaction
and the
like the the the song is just coming out
of him do you know what i mean
he's going like oh
and he starts laughing and he starts
singing and laughs
dude it's so dick hold on here we go
ready
oh man brother oh you're really a
wrestler man
oh oh oh
god damn
goddamn what
the guy tries to get away dude and he's
still walking
you know oh he got the belt now brother
you got the belt hold on can i see
brother got the goddamn
daddy
brother come on you ain't got no goddamn
dude
look hold on hold on man just hold on
brother damn can i talk to him man oh
let me rule come on brother hold on man
god damn
damn brother like the blue ranger
brother hold up
oh come on man
okay
come on one more time oh there come on
you wanna do that one you wanna do that
one
oh [ __ ] dude i i he wanted him to
[ __ ] like get at him that's a [ __ ]
hilarious dude
he wanted him to be [ __ ] mad oh god
damn it this guy makes me laugh dude
there was a there was one
where he was a you know what i gotta
look at it on my [ __ ] phone because i
sent it to my friend and i can pull it
up that way i mean this one dude is just
where he he's there's like a couple on
the on the uh
on the shoe here it is here it is
i think it is the first time i've ever
had cheese
apparently oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
oh [ __ ] i love the internet but i hate
i love the internet when it's on your
side but i hate it um
yeah dude jesus christ man that [ __ ]
makes me laugh and so you gotta [ __ ]
follow him slv
underscore sounds with two s's
you know get a better name um
my brother got the goddamn goddamn
goddamn jordan never did that move
let's look at another one of those just
for [ __ ] shits dude
here we go
it's not playing
[Music]
i just want to say a few words
oh man brother got the goddamn
it's a mustard sandwich right here oh
man hi
god damn look at this shoe
got these tied to the tip in town
single souls man i never seen this kind
of tim right here man
but what kind of chimneys is
these i don't know tim
got the coconut bread right here
with the lemon this the lemon lemon
right here the lemon lemon sprout
got three things bro let me rub
ah look at the crease oh
[Laughter]
look at the crease
sneakerheads hate creases and he's just
singing look at the crease while he
touches him
oh [ __ ] man
oh [ __ ]
man i got so much [ __ ] mucus man when
i drink coff or uh water and [ __ ] when i
drink too much water and [ __ ]
and i eat those [ __ ] cheese balls
from lala's kitchen or whatever
this i hit a bunch of [ __ ] cheese
balls and the [ __ ] mucus goes bonkers
man i got i got [ __ ] dummy cheese
balls right now dummy mucus in my
[ __ ] [ __ ]
from the chip from them cheese balls
um i was watching this documentary on um
this thing which i had no idea even
existed i don't know how i missed it
with
uh
with the internet i was on the internet
a lot in when they blew up
and i just [ __ ] maybe it's because it
was for women and i just not something i
would
care about but lularoe
did you see the documentary on netflix
lula rich
there's a company founded in 2012
and it was a multi-level marketing
company as they say but has you know a
lot of people that even work for them
say it was a pyramid scheme where you
would get most of the money
um
you'd get most of the money
for trying to get people to sign up but
the difference between a multi-level
marketing scheme or multi-level
marketing company
which is legal
and a pyramid scheme which is illegal is
that a multi-level marketing
company
uh has goods that they're actually
selling and a pyramid scheme i guess
doesn't
and uh they were selling
shirts and pants
that were just you know you could buy a
box of them and then sell them at a
higher price
but it was on you to try and get other
people
to sign up to also sell these things
and it was like a five thousand dollar
buy-in fee you know and i was watching
this documentary
and so
the
the the
you know how like
we live in a like a culture now where
everyone is like
you know
feels like they're a victim online
they'll just be like you know hey you
know i was
at nordstrom's and this
man or woman tried to [ __ ] upsell me
this isn't right you know and it's like
dude you're just
you kind of just got had you were or it
didn't happen you know or you're just
[ __ ] telling your side of the story
or whatever the [ __ ] it is but like so
that's
in my psyche ingrained in it now because
like i've seen people get mad at things
where i know it's
their fault i've seen it you know um
friends and and family and [ __ ] like
that but
but this now i'm watching this lularoe
thing and like everyone was a part of
this pyramid scheme building off of each
other's backs right the one percent of
the tippy top was making all the money
and now they're all broke
and they're all screaming that it's the
person above them's fault
when it's like
the pyramid doesn't exist if you don't
either
you know what i'm talking about okay
let's take the bottom level out of it
what about the top five levels
some people were like yeah you know i
was a part of it and it was shitty but
they're throwing around words like yeah
well these people were you know
uh predatory and [ __ ] dude
you're selling spanx
you bought a box of spanx
for 11
each
and you want to scream about dude you're
the f at what point are you the idiot at
what point is it your fault and i will
tell you i watched the five episodes of
this mini docu-series
for four and a half episodes
i was
i was on the top number one percent side
and i'm like they're i think they're
making this documentary
to like make us feel for the people who
got
had
and it's like i didn't until the last
part of the last episode i was like all
right i guess it was
unethical and shitty
but like i saw people that were like oh
man one episode in can't believe these
[ __ ] greed
uh uh manipulative manipulative [ __ ]
predatory it's like but it's spanx
you can't throw around these [ __ ]
words
sometimes you just got had
you know
if i buy a [ __ ] ballpark beef frank
and i took a bite into it and i
realized it's vegan
or an impossible
hot dog or whatever the [ __ ]
and and i find out the other dude who
sold it to me knows
i don't have to [ __ ] write home about
it oops that's my bad i [ __ ] up
it's not easy to make money
be on your guard
somebody says you know what
here's [ __ ] 5 000 worth of clothes
pay me five thousand dollars you can
make 50 grand off it and you will by the
end of the week
if i go
okay
i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and guess what if somebody did that to
me i'd have that in the back of my head
well i could turn this flip this money
okay i could do that
but that's on that person or that's on
me i know you know these people are out
there
you know every business you know most
businesses are not legit
but you're still oh but i'm the one
though
i'm the one who figured it out
this is my [ __ ] uh
this is my come up spanx
this is my come up
striped pants
that are comfy middle-aged women loved
it dude the mom's at home you could be
an entrepreneur and still have time for
your family no you can't
how about you can't remember the 90s
when you know stay at home mom stay at
home dad whatever the [ __ ] it was they
would just stay in the [ __ ] at home
there was no computer they were just
making sandwiches and cleaning up
that's what they were doing and i don't
mean to be sec it's men women whoever
was to stay at home whoever and i know
it was mostly women because that was the
[ __ ] very that time was a lot more
patriarchal than it is now but all i'm
saying is
now you got computers you got people on
the other end of those computers
trying to had you
it's not always
else's fault you know what i'm talking
about
i just i want people to [ __ ]
you know what i want people to just be
like all right
like these documentaries i watched dude
did you watch the [ __ ] one what was
the one the
the one that was
was so big a few years ago uh
the the brendan dassey or whatever the
[ __ ]
what the hell was that one called
making a murderer right you dude i
watched that [ __ ] on what was it i don't
know netflix or [ __ ] crunchyroll and
dude
i watched that [ __ ] thing and like
i'm watching it and i'm like wow this
guy didn't do it i can't believe that he
didn't do it and they made this [ __ ]
case oh
you do a quick [ __ ] google search
after all those episodes and in 25
seconds
you go like this
oh
he did it
and you had the [ __ ] nation up in
arms about how he didn't do this [ __ ]
google it google it for [ __ ] five and
a half minutes for real watch making a
murder google it for five and a half
minute minute
minutes afterwards
oh head at it
i had a buddy what was the other one
about the [ __ ] kids way back when who
remember our buddy that wanted to go to
[ __ ] louisiana to try to get the guys
out of prison what was that one called
ah [ __ ] what the hell was it called
the the three kids that they blamed on
it because they were goth
god damn it what the hell was it they
were like 16 year olds and everyone was
like they did it because they worshiped
the devil and they were like uh
we just like music with guitars in it
and they put them in jail forever and
like
you know they apparently they didn't do
it because they were freed
wasn't it called free something
freeing i don't know
no no no it's not that but um yeah they
they uh you know what i'm talking about
if you're listening and you've seen it
you know which one i'm talking about but
they [ __ ] i get the the guy did like
time like two decades and then he
finally let him out and we had a [ __ ]
actor friend i had a [ __ ] actor
friend a while ago we're not really
friends anymore but he was like i'm
gonna go and i'm gonna [ __ ] try and
petition and i'm like bro just do your
[ __ ] guest star a [ __ ] ncsi you
know
you're not gonna help
also maybe they did it
you're just a i mean we've come to know
that they didn't do it but you don't
know dude you're just acting in a
[ __ ]
you know you did a movie with dennis
quaid and now you're like i'm gonna
stand outside of the prison until they
let them out
what is it
paradise lost that's what it is
look at it it's pretty crazy though dude
[ __ ] goddamn
lularoe
look it's still on too god this [ __ ]
blew up so quickly in like one year it
was a billion dollar company
and here i am watching this documentary
and i'm like how do i [ __ ] make this
billion dollar company you know what
happens kanye west elon musk steve jobs
they did it
lularoe they did it
and some of them crashed but there's a
way to do this [ __ ] and then my next
thought
ah nah
nah
can't really do that
it's like playing the lottery yeah hard
work sure yeah you could do with hard
work yeah
hey go ahead go do it with hard work
go ahead
okay well let me get all the [ __ ]
paperwork involved yeah go ahead go get
that paperwork all right let me go get
some [ __ ] funding and [ __ ] yeah go
for it man come on champ go get the
funding ah cool and let me meet with
[ __ ] product uh uh developers and
then management and all that [ __ ] yeah
go for it champ you got this
yeah
all right
now what i don't know all right i'll
figure it out yeah champ you go figure
it out and then you'll be one of those
guys who makes it through that actually
isn't in the red
or
just stack your money and work at crate
and barrel and one day
one day
you'll have enough to take a week
vacation every year
you know
what's the right way i don't know it's
nice to have a dream it's real nice to
have a dream
but most of the time
dreams
are dreams
right
people say dare to dream
but
man it's kind of daring
to just chill
you know what i'm talking about
you know i'm talking about daring the
dream dreaming is [ __ ] easy and even
trying
the first few steps your dream that's
[ __ ] easy too
chilling
daring
dare to chill
you know there's that whole quote i
forget who said it
that might have been bill burr but he
was like you know
nah it's not hard it's not hard to
[ __ ] do hard work because the
opposite is terrifying maybe it wasn't
bill but the opposite is terrifying you
know like living every day and just not
achieving it and becoming somebody that
you realize you never wanted to become
that's that's what's terrifying i think
it was yeah i think was bill
uh yeah
nah you know nah nah though you know
it's so scary to go out there and do
this [ __ ]
that's why i'm that's why most people
chill
dare to chill bro
otherwise you're looking for a shortcut
right multi-multi-level marketing scheme
and sometimes it works
lularoe
i need to do spanx is what i need to do
i need to sell spanx i got the new merch
um make friends in the comments
uh we re-upped it we put it on patreon
and people on patreon ate it up and then
we [ __ ] re-upped it and put it out to
the public and uh you can go we got the
stuff right here we'll show you right
here in the in the image but it's make
friends we got the hoodie the mint the
mint green hoodie the tan t-shirt and
then the pink long sleeve which is
[ __ ] i can't wait to cozy up on that
[ __ ] hoodie make friends in the
comments you see someone talking [ __ ] if
you're looking at an artist's page on
instagram and you see someone your music
isn't as good as it was you say hey bud
to that person want to go to red robin
you make friends with that [ __ ]
because that's what they need man
dude i was in line at the
starbucks i went to starbucks because it
was closer even though the
even though that coffee sucks so [ __ ]
hard um
and uh i saw this lady with the the the
she had such a [ __ ]
fake butt
i i
it's actually insane to me that um
people
because you gotta you gotta think look
if you're a lady with a fake butt you
also have fake lips now look let me
preface this by saying i'm in la
everyone walking around looks like a
duck even the [ __ ]
chicks gay dudes even some regular dudes
that are just look regular but straight
and they some of them have [ __ ] duck
like i know guys who have gotten work
done like i know 50 year old comedians
that have gotten work done which is
[ __ ] crazy right
and
um
but like i saw a woman with a fake ass
[Music]
and i knew i actually knew a a woman
with a fake ass
uh years ago and she was like would like
you know my friend was like seeing her
and she would like
show she showed up like for a week or
two with like a one of those [ __ ]
donuts that you sit on and like she
would come out and sit down
like at the comedy shows or wherever the
[ __ ] and she would have like a
sit on a donut she would bring this
[ __ ] big donut to sit on
and everyone would be like what is going
on and she'd be like oh it's just a
thing i have to do the doctor said and
it's like
he got a fake
ass we all know
because your back went straight down a
week ago
and now i could set my drink down on it
your back went straight down a week ago
and now
i got a place to lay my sprite
but it's just like these fake asses are
getting bigger and bigger and also
the chicks will get either it's weird
because like in la i used to go to this
gym that was just like
there would be women with fake asses but
they would also be working out which
makes like kind of no sense because it's
like you're doing the hard work but also
you're doing the not the fake [ __ ]
but then it's like you kind of gotta do
that because
if you don't
then
your [ __ ] just looks like an upside down
musical note
right like your ass
is that big bulbous thing
and then you've got like two [ __ ] kid
legs just dangling
like two two [ __ ] carrots that just
got plucked
and that's gross
but also just
stop getting fake asses
and don't get fake lips either i know i
get it you're probably listening to this
you have fake lips and that's fine look
ultimately you know me i want you to do
you and what makes you happy
and uh
if fake lips makes you happy cool
if a fake butt makes you hap if you like
sitting a little higher
great
but the fake butt the fake lips i mean
there's people out there fake butt fake
lips
eyes done
face lift fake boobs
ribs taken out
fake tan
you know fake nails
and it's like basically you're just
turning yourself into one of the aliens
from battlefield earth
um
and then dudes are out there just like
in a shirt and jeans i get it the
pressures of
you know
women being beautiful are i you know i
don't get it they're it's tough but also
you know
dad left early
dad died early
um nah just [ __ ] chill sit down where
you're supposed to sit down the fake
asses are weird as [ __ ] man
i uh i'm gonna get one
i'm gonna get a big fake ass
and take shits in my pants
and just [ __ ] walk around with shits
in my pants and people be like you [ __ ]
your pants and i'll just say stop
looking at my fake ass
just walk in a [ __ ] low cinema bro
fat [ __ ] fake ass [ __ ]
just walk into a [ __ ] low cinema yeah
let me get the big popcorn
[ __ ] [ __ ] out my fake bubble ass
feet dangling like some carrots
yeah i [ __ ] my [ __ ] fake ass
too please
for me and my [ __ ] homie
matinee
just walking in a [ __ ]
united artist theater
yeah two for the [ __ ] latest uh
vin diesel travesty
bra
sorry i just [ __ ] my fake ass where do i
go
um
i went to my dentist and we've and my
my jaw still [ __ ] hurts dude my my my
tmj disorder whatever the [ __ ]
the the
the
the soft
the i don't know what it is cartilage or
some [ __ ] it slipped and it's not going
back and i can still [ __ ] talk thank
god but it didn't help you know he gave
me a bite plate that [ __ ] didn't help
then we went in and he adjusted it i've
had it for two nights this shit's the
same i wake up every morning it's like
somebody just took a hammer and nail to
my [ __ ] jaw on the left side i can't
even eat a sandwich hurts so [ __ ] bad
it's not gonna help you know
um but that's that
i guess that's it
we're just chilling dude
crystalia.com for all your [ __ ] merch
uh
been on stage a few times who knows
it's been cool
it's been good and bad up and down uh
but we're having a good time
in life i love my son
and i love my family
and my daddy and mommy
hey guys that's it for the episode on
youtube if you want to catch the rest of
the episode the uncut episode uh plus
many more episodes that aren't on
youtube just go to patreon.com
crystalia and we'll see you there we
also have other segments that we do and
other behind the scenes stuff and
different things that we do there's a
discord where we chat we watch along on
the podcast and if you want to do that
then do that uh patreon.com if not we
appreciate you anyway bye
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
did i already say cozy [ __ ] man hold on